We're given two points, so we can start by finding the slope. I'm going to label
this point x1, y1, and this point x2, y2. For y2, I plug in 5. For y1, I plug in
negative 1. And for x2, I plug in negative 2. And finally, for x1, we plug in 3.
5 plus 1 makes 6 and negative 2 minus 3 is negative 5, so we have negative 6
5ths as our slope. Now that we have the slope, we can use our slope formula
again and fix one of the points to be x and y. These two variables will appear
in our equation. We can plug in negative 6 5ths in for the slope and then we can
use our other point 3 and negative 1 for x1 and y1, that's this point here.
Simplifying the y minus negative 1, I get y plus 1. Now that we're here, we want
to find an equation in slope intercept form, so we want to solve this equation
for y. I can multiply both sides by 5 times x minus 3. We do this as 5 times x
minus 3 is a common denominator for these two fractions. Notice that we just
have factors that appear in the numerator, and also in the denominators. This x
minus 3 is just one factor. We use these factors to help us simplify. We know 5
divided by 5 makes 1, and x minus 3 divided by x minus 3 also makes 1. So we
have x minus 3 times negative 6 equals y plus 1 times 5. We could have gotten to
this step just by cross-multiplying. Negative 6 times x minus 3 on the left. And
5 times y plus 1 on the right. Pretty cool. I distribute the negative 6 to the x
and the negative 3. And I distribute the 5 to the y and the positive 1. Our goal
here is to get y by itself. So let's isolate this 5y term. We can subtract 5
from both sides to get negative 6x plus 13 equals 5 times y, and then we divide
both sides of our equation by 5. So I have negative 6 5ths times x on the left,
but 13 5ths equals 1y. It's probably best to continue solving down the page, I
just wanted to show our work all in one place. I can rewrite this fraction as
negative 6 5ths times x. We know multiplication and division have the same
priority in the order of operations. I could do multiplication, and then the
division. Or I could do division, and then the multiplication. These two are
exactly the same. Finally, we can just flip our equation around to get our
answer in slope intercept form. We can check one part of our answer. We
calculated the slope to be negative 6 5ths earlier in our problem. Well sure
enough, we get negative 6 5ths in our answer. We know that this part of the
problem should be correct so long as our calculation from above was correct.